seeing Jennifer Lopez performing the
role of a dancer in a movie may not seem
that surprising she's known for her
moves but knowing how to dance and
knowing how to do this are two very
different things turns out even JLo
needed some help to get ready to assume
her role as an experienced pole dancer
and hustlers
that's why ten-year veteran of Cirque de
Soleil Johanna sabaki comes in even
though it was just a short period of
time she's throwing out these moves
without even thinking about it anymore
so how did the pocky get Lopez to the
point where she was doing upside down
splits in just two months
[Music]
Lopez took her training so seriously
that she moved a portable pole into each
one of her houses in New York City Los
Angeles and Miami so that she could
continue to practice wherever she
happened to be living at the time while
Lopez was already in fantastic shape
pole dancing requires certain muscle
groups to be extraordinarily strong and
because there are no body doubles in the
film she had to do everything herself so
to get her ready for the role so pocky
first made sure that lopez was
exercising the muscle groups that she'd
need to pull dance like a pro Lopez
worked with her personal trainer to
strengthen her core and upper body you
have to make sure that she was strong
enough to perform certain moves like the
inverted splits where she's supporting
her entire body weight with just her
arms and shoulders as Lopez continued to
strengthen her body in the gym she also
began her pole dancing training sessions
with papaki
so [ __ ] says that each training session
always started with stretching it's
important to loosen the spine shoulders
and hips in order to provide a wider
range of motion for the undulating
movements that are central to pole
dancing after stretching so [ __ ] slowly
introduced Lopez to the principles of
pole dancing such as basic spins and
climbing when we started
you know the trainings are are slow you
do one movement at a time you rest in
between if you're not used to a lot of
rotation getting the feeling of spinning
around the pole takes a little bit of
practice there's a lot of conversation
about you know how to do the movement
and what the movement is so pocky also
emphasized improving Lopez's pole
dancing endurance
she knew Lopes was going to have to do
her pulled in some scenes over and over
and over again throughout the day when
they were filming especially because her
main routine was a full four minutes
long you're not just doing one trick at
a time you're linking things together
into you know two three four minutes
worth of movement she's doing takes from
different angles over and over again and
she has to nail it every single time
because sabaki also choreographed all of
the bull dancing scenes and hustlers she
knew exactly what moves Lopez was going
to have to perform for the film
there were several particularly
difficult moves in the choreography but
sabaki was confident in Lopez's
abilities there's one where she actually
wraps her legs around the pole and just
squeezes with her inner thighs and
that's a fall that she's using to hold
on and that definitely took some
practice because you really have to
engage those inner thigh muscles in
order to hold yourself on the fall so
that's not one that came on day one we
definitely had to work up to that in
order to gain that feeling and that
strength once Lopez started to get
confident with her pole dancing the last
thing for her to master was flipping
upside down you want to make sure that
physically you're really capable before
you're inverting it takes a lot of core
strength it takes a lot of grip strength
and it takes a lot of upper-body
strength
to physically pull yourself up and then
maintain that position safely when Lopez
was first learning the move so pocky
would provide a spot for her making sure
she was safe as she tried to master the
movement but it wasn't too long before
she was able to do it on her own she
really became comfortable with it
quickly because of her work ethic and
cuz she was so diligent and determined
to get it right she was able to achieve
her goal by the end which was turning
upside down and ultimately looking like
she's been doing this her whole life and
that that was really exciting to see and
really satisfying
[Music]